el derecho al aborto vuelve a agitar
eeuu desde el 24 de junio la corte
suprema derogará la protección a la
interrupción del embarazo a escala
federal la decisión sobre su regulación
recae en cada uno de los 50 estados pero
a nivel nacional exige la protección de
la gestante por encima de todo un
incumplimiento por el cual el ejecutivo
de idaho ya ha sido denunciado por la
fiscalía o la house pro cuando un
hospital determina que un aborto es el
tratamiento médico necesario para
estabilizar la condición médica de
emergencia de un paciente está obligado
por la ley federal a proporcionar ese
tratamiento como se detalla en nuestra
demanda la ley de idaho convertiría en
un delito penal el hecho de que los
médicos proporcionará el tratamiento
médico de emergencia que exige la ley
federal ferro world wars la batalla
legal por el aborto se ha recrudecido en
la última semana en territorios como
indiana kentucky o michigan cuyo
tribunal de apelaciones falló que los
fiscales de los condados puedan prohibir
una ley casi centenaria que sigue
enfrentando a demócratas y republicanos
quiero dejar una cosa muy clara el
aborto sigue siendo y legal en michigan
hoy en día la orden judicial que prohíbe
la aplicación de la prohibición penal
del aborto en michigan de 1931 sigue en
vigor y sigue aplicándose a todos los
fiscales de los condados de michigan
tras la derogación de roe versus wait la
prohibición a la interrupción del
embarazo ya es una realidad de nueve
estados y en más de veinte hay
restricciones las cuales dinamizan el
debate en un país que en noviembre
renueva la totalidad del senado y un
tercio de la cámara de representantes